-I have a few more questions
about your work in
the boy-band/girl-band genre
But when you first came
to New York,
where did you come
straight from?
Were you working in Florid
at the time?
-I came from Universal Studios
I had worked at Disney
performing,
and then I was performing
at Universal Studios
at the "Murder, She Wrote"
post-production show.
-Wow.
-And I played an editor
or an ADR person
and different people
that put together
the episode of
"Murder, She Wrote."
And, so, I did that
and got a call
to come to interview at "SNL
from the green room of
Universal Studios Theme Park
-I'm always fascinated
with people's first
New York City apartments.
What was your --
What did you find for yourself
as a young writer?
-I kind of took
the first one I saw
'cause I thought it was cute
but the guy who was my
real-estate guy was sweating
It was winter, I think.
It was late fall.
And he was sweating,
and he was super intense,
and he kept using
the word "sick" as positive,
which I did not know.
I was not savvy
to the word "sick."
So he would just
show me things and go,
"The kitchen at this place
is sick!"
And I thought it was bad,
and I was like,
"Why is he so excited
about showing me
this terrible kitchen?"
And then he described
this apartment, which, you know,
was soon after I realized
that all of real-estate
New York descriptions
are bull crap.
And, so, he would say, you know,
"It has a prewar kitchen.
Vintage prewar kitchen
with copper detailing."
And I would picture this,
like, you know, weird tiling
that was all from the 1800
of copper.
And it was like
a '90s gay man's kitchen
that was teal,
and it had copper,
like, smears of paint
that looked like
a total '80s video.
And, then, it would say, like,
"garden window."
And you would look out,
and there was like, you know
half a diaper and a pigeon
and then, like, one plant
that was half-dead.
So that was my first place
I lived.
And it was next to H&H Bagels,
which really was --
I was like Pepé Le Pew
going out every day
to the smell of hot bread.
And I still am.
-You wrote a sketch
called "7 Degrees Celsius.
-Mm-hmm.
-This was a boy band.
This is cast members.
That's James Van Der Beek.
-That was "The Beek."
-"The Beek."
And you also got to write
for 'NSYNC.
-Yeah, you know, I did tha
as recurring characters,
those four --
You know, Parnell, Jimmy Fallon,
Horatio, and Kattan.
They were --
I made a fake boy band.
They had really weird
facial hair,
and Will was the manager
and could only be 300 feet
from them due to a court case.
And they had tinted glasses,
the whole shebang.
And I would write the song
and everything.
And then 'NSYNC
was the music guest,
and I think someone suggeste
or I suggested, like,
they can be the guest boy band
fake boy band on there.
So I wrote the song
called "Hold the Pickle,"
where they were fast-food guys
and they had
McDonald's outfits on.
And they were saying like...
♪♪ Hold the pickle
and do it up big ♪♪
And it was all about
being in love and holding
the pickle and all of this
and it was very sexual.
And they couldn't
come and rehearse it
until the very last minute
And these guys took a whil
to learn things.
-[ Laughs ]
Wait. Wait. This crew?
You're telling me they weren't
great with choreography?
-It was a little rough.
It was like teaching goats how
to sing and dance at that point.
Jimmy and Parnell were --
They were all trying very hard
But sometimes
they'd kind of be scattered off,
and I'd have to keep
getting them back.
But 'NSYNC comes in,
and I hand them the, you know --
I say "Xeroxed"
because I'm 96 years old.
And I handed them, you know,
the copies of the thing.
And they immediately, like
whispered to each other
in a huddle.
And then they get out
and do full four-part harmony,
just kick flips, like,
full dance number to it.
Like, "Yeah,
let's just do this."
And they do the whole thing.
And I was just in complete awe
But that was really my exposur
to the sort of
boy-group/girl-group stuff
a lot, was when I was
sort of parodying them.
I have such a vivid memory
of coming home --
You know,
on Sundays after "SNL,"
it's like you're really
unpacking your feelings
of failure or success
and your two martinis
at the after-party.
And I would just never leave
the apartment --
that apartment with the sick -
the sick kitchen.
I would never leave.
I would just order --
I'd wake up at 2:00,
order carryout,
and just stay in that cocoon
all day.
And I turned on "TRL,"
at the time that was still on,
and there were
all these screaming girls
'cause it was 'NSYNC.
And I looked down --
They showed down out the window.
And it was all these girls
And it was hours
after the show ended at "SNL."
And they had a giant banne
that said, "Hold the pickle.
So that means all those
little girls sat and painted -
poster paint
in the middle of the night -
and made their mom go get
poster paint at Duane Reade.
And they made this -- And
it was one of those first time
at that show that I realized
how immediate everything was
where it was like,
"Oh, this is really truly...
uh, live." [ Sighs ]
-Well, Paula, thank you.
-I realized I had no real
big-bang finisher for that
so I just thought I would
connect with you as an audienc
and just be human.
I'd be human
and connect with you.
-"Girls5eva" is streaming no
on Peacock.